from chess bursting aliens to
eye-popping vacations on mars
science fiction has always been a genre
warning us of the dangers of the future
like what if we could predict crime take
political correctness too far
or bang an alien in this video we'll be
taking a chronological look at some of
the greatest sci-fi films of all time
how well do you think they accurately
predict the future and
word of warning i'm only choosing films
that have verified dates
and take place in the future from when
the film was made so i'm sorry star wars
you just don't make the cut
starting off with a director who has
four entries in the timeline is
james cameron's the abyss one of a few
on this list that doesn't take place in
space
or some sort of dystopian future
although theatrically released in 1989
the film is set five years in the future
when an experimental drilling platform
on the bottom of the ocean has an
unexpected run-in with
underwater aliens although one of
cameron's least successful films it did
end up grossing 90 million of its 45
million dollar budget
and was one of the first films to
implement photorealistic fluid morphing
using cgi
three years later and the world isn't
looking too great well
new york at least which has turned the
whole island of manhattan into a maximum
security prison it's directed by john
carpenter and stars kurt russell as
legendary snake pliskin a man who must
infiltrate the criminal infested island
to save the president or else his
arteries will explode escape from new
york may not be the greatest
representation of new york in 1997
well okay maybe it was but it's gone on
to be a cult classic
arguably one of the most groundbreaking
and critically acclaimed films on the
timeline is stanley kubrick's 2001 a
space odyssey
a film you guessed it set in 2001 but
made in 1968.
its groundbreaking practical effects
would go on to be used by directors like
christopher nolan in inception
and the iconic computer ai known as hal
still makes me freak out anytime i see
electronics with a red light on them
although it may not be the best
representation of what space travel
would be like in 2001
heck we haven't even landed on the moon
since 1972
2001 paved the way for how future
science fiction films would be created
fast forward to 2015 and detroit's on
the verge of collapse due to financial
mismanagement and a high crime rate so
basically robocop was banging on
your move it makes us question the roles
corporations have on our safety and what
really makes us human as robocop
struggles with the memories of his past
which were supposed to be erased if you
like action with a sci-fi twist
definitely check this one out in the
same year but completely different
is back to the future too a film made in
1989 but depicting
2015. plus there's no weird your mom
trying to bang you stuff
robert zemeckis's second installment of
the franchise sees marty mcfly having to
travel not only into the past
but into the future fun fact actor
crispin glover who played marty's dad in
the original movie
was replaced by an actor with
prosthetics including a fake chin nose
and cheekbones to resemble glover
after the actor refused to come back
regardless the film ended up being the
highest grossing film of 1989.
one of my favorites on this list is
1987's the running man
set in 2017 it sees a popular game show
host torment arnold schwarzenegger as
america falls into ruin
so basically it's spot on the running
man is one of those truly unique films
portraying a world hell bent on
punishing those accused of crimes
in a system that's secretly rigged
against those who play it it's really
kind of interesting
to see how much of the themes of
societal and criminal injustice
hold up to today and if you haven't
checked out this one it's worth it just
for dynamo
[Music]
one of two ridley scott films on this
list is 1982's blade runner depicting a
2019
los angeles although visually stunning
it's far from the la of today
but enough can't be said how this film
inspired future generations of sci-fi
filmmakers blade runner follows rick
deckard a man in charge of tracking down
bioengineered humanoids known as
replicants
it's one of those films that makes us
really question what it means to be
human and if you want to know the answer
to that
like and subscribe answer at 1 million
subs next up is edge of tomorrow set
right now
in 2020 and who could have predicted
this world where alien creatures known
as mimics threaten humanity's very
existence could be
slightly better than the 2020 we're
living now tom cruise and emily blunt
star in this groundhog day-esque
actioner where cruz's william cage must
relive the same battle
over and over again the special effects
are superb here with them realistically
making tom cruise taller than emily
blunt
so good on the vfx team for that now
we're heading into the future in
a very grim one at that with alfonso
cueron's
children of men set in 2027 after 18
years of
total human infertility and global
depression humanity faces extinction
clive owen plays theo farron a former
activist
turned bureaucrat who teams up with a
militant immigrants rights group
protecting the planet's only known
pregnant woman
if you're looking for a movie to
brighten your day in these trying times
yeah this probably isn't the one for you
but it's absolutely brilliant and worth
the watch
another one of my favorites on the list
the original terminator although the
majority of the film takes place in the
80s
the future it depicts is the year 2029
in which the last of humanity fights
against the machines
a cyborg assassin is sent back in time
to 1984 to kill sarah connor the woman
who will one day give birth to a son who
will lead humanity to victory i mean i
wish i could go back in time just to
watch this movie for the first time
again
if you haven't seen it just turn off
this video and watch it asap up next is
bong joon ho's
post apocalyptic train adventure snow
piercer based off the french graphic
novel le transpistenege i just love
saying that
snowpiercer sees a world where man's
attempt to stop global warming
completely backfires resulting in a new
ice age the remnants of humanity take to
the snow piercer a train that
circumnavigates the globe and slowly
becomes segregated with the rich living
and extravagant life in the front
and the poor a life of squalor in the
back it's a totally weird and unique
movie plus captain america is in it so
you should give it a watch
if you're wanting a completely
over-the-top look at future california
look no further than the megalopolis
known as san angeles in 1993's
demolition man it sees a perfect utopian
california
where there's almost no crime but it's
terribly oppressive as almost everything
fun like swearing has been declared
illegal
thanks a lot you [ __ ]
it's just a totally fun cat and mouse
game where sylvester stallone has to
track down wesley snipes for his taxes
and is one of the few films on this list
that has a different take on the future
one in which we go too far politically
correct heading down the line to 2035 is
terry gilliam's 12 monkeys yet another
film about a virus almost wiping out
humanity in which bruce wilson's
character must travel to 1996
to stop it from ever being released it
was written by the same writing duo as
blade runner based off the short film
lagete which
i had to watch a hundred times in film
school it is a star-studded cast with
willis and brad pitt
but surprisingly not a lot of monkeys
the wachowski's second-ready credit
after the matrix trilogy is another
dystopian future
set in britain what is with these
writers always choosing britain anyway v
for vendetta depicts the exploits of
elrond i mean the masked vigilante known
as v
take on an authoritarian regime six
weeks into filming v
who was originally played by james
purifoy left the production and was
later replaced by hugo weaving who
redubbed his voice if you want great
action and a compelling story
definitely check this one out ryan
johnson's looper yeah i know some of you
have a hate on for mr johnson
is another one of those must-see sci-fi
time travel films and if you would have
told me joseph gordon levitt could pull
off a young bruce willis i'd have told
you you're a filthy liar but it actually
kinda works the story here is really
interesting seeing bounty hunters call
loopers who are hired to terminate
victims sent back through time by crime
syndicates
based on the wildly popular sci-fi novel
of the same name
ready player 1 is set in the year 2045
where people seek escape from reality
through a virtual reality universe
called
oasis this is the first of three steven
spielberg films on this list who is no
stranger to sci-fi
although not a huge critical success the
film ended up grossing close to 600
million two years later we have event
horizon which sees sam neil and laurence
fishburn on a rescue mission to a
missing ship that spontaneously appears
around neptune
of course things don't go according to
plan as it's discovered the ship is
under the control of a malevolent entity
god i hate it when that happens speaking
of things not going well we have
minority report where tom cruise must
evade authorities as he's deemed guilty
of a crime he's yet to commit the film
delves into the classic philosophical
debate of free will vs determinism
are we bound by fate or do we really
make our own choices
believe it or not this was supposed to
be a sequel to the original total recall
don't ask me how that works i just
thought that was pretty cool three years
later the sun is dying and earth is
freezing
in danny boyle sunshine eight astronauts
are tasked with jump starting the sun
but as you can imagine it's about as
easy as it sounds things go terribly
wrong i mean this killian murphy guy
can't catch a break in his movies he
also starred in boyle's 28 days later
let's jump 10 years to 2067 and another
film about a group of astronauts tasked
with saving the planet christopher
nolan's interstellar is an epic journey
through space and time starring matthew
mcconaughey anne hathaway and a 15 year
old timothy chalamet made with an
estimated budget of 165 million
interstellar killed it at the box office
earning almost 700 million
another one of my favorites on the list
the original total recall
originally written by the same
screenwriters as alien this screenplay
set in the year 2084
went through almost that many drafts
before it was actually greenlit not
really it was
closer to 42 but still patrick swayze
was originally considered for the main
role but when dino de laurentiis other
film
dune flopped at the box office he
released the rights to the script where
schwarzenegger picked it up
and loved it teaming up with paul
verhoeven the director of robocop which
schwarzenegger was also supposed to star
in
continuing deeper into the future is
another spielberg entry ai
starring hayley joel osmond a realistic
ai child capable of simulating love for
years this project was developed by
stanley kubrick but lingered in
development hell
partly because the technology at the
time was unable to properly convey
kubrick's vision
after his death in 1999 the script was
given to spielberg and the rest is
history
21 years later the crew of the
commercial space tugnos trombo brings on
board an alien creature in one of this
timeline's most terrifying films
believe it or not actress sigourney
weaver was the last one to be cast with
her doing screen tests
in the studio as the sets were being
built the film was a huge success making
roughly 20 times its budget back
more than 30 years later were introduced
to the navi 2154 sees james cameron
explore the world of pandora and up
until recently it was the highest
grossing film of all time with two
sequels on the way and heavy investment
from disney
only time will tell if cameron's epic
trilogy will live up to its blockbuster
hit original
and if there's one filmmaker up to the
task of making a sequel to alien
guess who it is again none other than
james cameron the 1986 follow-up is set
57 years after the events of the first
film
picking up right where protagonist
ripley left off in cryosleep whereas the
original was more horror inspired
aliens leans to action and to this day a
huge debate rages which film is superior
let me know which film you think is
better in the comments below
one of the most groundbreaking films on
this list is 1999's the matrix
although you'd think the film takes
place in the present that's all of us
saw the real world is run by machines
who harvest humans for energy
in the year 2199 the movie was so
successful it spawned two sequels with a
fourth schedule to release in 2021
and keanu reeves will reprise his role
as neo as if things couldn't get worse
1997 starship troopers sees humanity at
war against an interstellar insectoid
species known as arachnids
director paul verhoeven in the dvd
commentary said that the film's message
is that war makes fascists of us all
hence the allusions to nazis throughout
but he caught flack for his comments on
american imperialism saying that the ss
imagery and propaganda is the natural
evolution of the united states the next
film has a special place in my heart so
get out your multi-passes because it's
the fifth element
set in the year 2263 this is yet another
film tasking bruce willis with saving
the earth and damn is it fun
it's a film that doesn't take itself too
seriously i mean come on it has gary
oldman playing an over-the-top villain
and it has one of the most futuristic
depictions of earth we've seen yet
up next the original star trek the
motion picture in the year 2273. the
film pits admiral james t
kirk and the crew of the newly refitted
starship enterprise against a
powerful alien cloud on its release it
smashed the record for highest opening
weekend gross beating the original
superman's opening of 10.4 million a
year later we have logan's run
along with starring basil from the
austin powers franchise it's just got a
really cool premise where the last of
humanity lives in this giant dome run by
a computer
but are killed off in an event known as
the carousel once they reach the age of
30 to prevent overpopulation
if you want some old school sci-fi check
this one out and last but certainly not
least
is planet of the apes now i said i'd
only choose films with actual dates but
i just had to add this one to the list
if not for charlton heston
take your stinking paws off me you
damn dirty ape it sees an earth so far
in the future that apes have taken over
this movie spawned like a million
terrible sequels and let's not forget
that fantastic musical sequence from the
simpsons
[Music]
that's it for this timeline of sci-fi
films leave a comment below on what your
favorites are on this list or if i left
yours out please make sure to like
subscribe and share and you can also
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much